Oh, Roxy's here. I'm going to take care.
You're the last one. Roxy, what's up?
>> Hey. Hey, you can hear me. Okay. I'm
outside.
>> I can hear you good now.
>> Okay. Um, yes. So, about the prayer, um,
because I grew up charismatic
and
then became
a Calvinist. So, I'm really confused
about what I'm how I'm to approach
>> how you're to what
>> how to approach
praying
>> uh praying in tongues. And
>> yeah, I don't know what like what what
exactly you mean. Be more specific as I
try to go see if my cat wants to come
in. Hold on. It's been out for
>> so
>> like I understand there's a formal
setting um like with somebody will pray
in tongues and there's an interpreter. I
get that in church but as far as like a
a personal you're just praying and you
don't know what to say kind of
>> well
>> that
>> you don't know what to say. Be more I
still don't get it. Be more specific.
>> Just
>> Yeah. What do you mean?
Um just I mean all I can say is it's
like a different language. It's like
praying in tong say praying. Well I
don't know. Do you have that gift? Do
you have you prayed in tongues? I don't
know.
>> Well well yes I can. But I I don't know
if I'm supposed to do it outside of a
church that
>> before you wonder if you should do it.
What I'm asking is when you start
praying in tongues was that something
they trained you to say or it just came?
>> I wanted to do it and then I prayed to
do it and then I started doing it. It's
like 20 years ago.
>> When I say doing it, there's people who
then try to tell you say this sh and
then they manipulate you to say it or
just it just happens.
>> It just happens.
>> Okay. That's so you 20 years ago just
when you asked to see if God's will was
for you to speak in languages, the word
is languages because tongues confuse
people. The Greek word is language. All
of a sudden, you started speaking in a
language you didn't understand, right?
>> Yes. And it's been for 20 years.
>> Yes.
>> And no one manipulated you. Just did it.
>> I just they could just do it. I mean,
all right.
>> Whether say anything, I don't know. It's
just
>> Okay. But see, this is again your fear
that we tried to resolve and rectify
last time when you came on and the Lord
gave you deliverance. So, I don't know.
Have you been delivered from your fear?
>> Yes. But that's a long story. Yes, Sam.
Um, there's been a lot going on with
that. But this is I just I'm just trying
to make sure I'm not doing anything
wrong.
>> Yeah. Because the reason I'm asking you
is because for 20 years you've been
praying in a language that you are not
certain whether it's of God and you keep
doing it for 20 years. So that means
there's something wrong with that
picture. If you were having doubts
whether this is of God, then why then do
it for 20 years?
You know the Bible says that if you do
something with doubt, you're sinning,
right? Romans 14:23. You're in sin. When
you are doubtful and double-minded about
doing something and you go ahead and do
it, you're sinning. That's Romans 14:23.
>> Yeah, which is why I'm asking.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm trying to show
you. That you need to solve your
problems immediately and not prolong
them. That's what I'm trying to get at.
Because for 20 years you've been praying
this prayer language a tongue but you're
not certain whether it's of God and yet
that uncertainty is what made it sin
because you know Romans 14:23
but he who doubts is condemned if he
eats and it's not about food that if you
doubt all foods are clean and if you
still have that doubt you go ahead and
eat because he does not eat from faith
for whatever is not from faith is sin.
If you don't truly believe it's of God
and you're doubting, then you're sinning
because you're doubting whether this is
from God, right, as a favor of God and a
freedom.
>> So that means you've been doing that for
20 years. Okay. Now, to answer your
question, number one, there's nothing in
the Bible that explicitly says these
languages that people are enabled to
pray in has stopped. So if I go with
scripture, so if we're going with
scripture, nothing in the Bible says it,
stop. It says, "These gifts are yours
until the revelation of Jesus Christ."
First Corinthians 1:7-8. In fact, do you
have your Bible or do I need to read it
for you?
>> Um, if you wouldn't mind reading it for
me. I'm outside.
>> Here, let me show you. So, as far as
scripture is concerned, I cannot tell
you that these gifts have seized. That
doesn't mean everyone speaks in tongues
is speaking by God because same can also
deceive people. Because what I look to
is the way you live and your doctrine.
Do you have sound doctrine and you're
living a life pleasing Lord? That is
what matters to me. But hold on, let me
just prove my point.
>> Okay.
>> 1 Corinthians 1:7 to8.
So this is why you'll have even ancient
traditions like the Catholic Church, the
Catholic Church that has a huge
charismatic move. It's called Catholic
Charismatics. These are Catholics that
speak in tonesues and pray the rosary in
tones. Did you know that?
>> I actually heard about that earlier
today.
>> See, confirmation, right? 1 Corinthians
1:17.
>> So that you are not lacking in any
spiritual gift. Now, guess what the word
spiritual gift is?
>> Charismat.
>> Charismata.
>> That's where you get charismatic gifts.
>> Charismata. Charismatic gifts. In fact,
here is a Catholic charismatic. Ordo
sancti Benedicti. That's me. See, he has
the gift of tongues or languages. Okay,
now watch 1 Corinthians 1:17. So that
you are not lacking in any spiritual
gift as you wait for the revealing of
our Lord Jesus Christ. So these gifts
that will thoroughly furnish you to be
solid in the faith are yours until when?
>> Until we're made complete. Until
>> until when in this passage?
>> Until the day of our Lord Jesus Christ.
>> Okay. So that means these gifts will be
with the church until Christ returns.
>> Yes.
>> Who will sustain you? Who will empower
enable all believers if they remain
faithful to him to be guiltless on the
day of our Lord Jesus Christ. Now that's
when the complete shows up. Meaning
these gifts will no longer be needed
when the perfection comes. Completion
comes. When we are perfected and made
whole. Here let me show it to you. 1
Corinthians 13:8
12. You ready?
>> Yes.
So as far as scriptur is concerned, the
languages have not stopped as far as
scriptures are concerned. And there are
churches who agree like the Catholic
Church agrees. But then there may be
churches say no, we believe it's seized.
All right. Well, that's their tradition.
And if you believe in that, then all
right, keep that prayer language to
yourself. So let me first show you that
as far as scripture is concerned, these
gifts are yours until the Lord returns.
1 Corinthians 13:8-12,
love never ends. That that will never
end. Love is everlasting because God is
love and he's everlasting. But as for
prophecies, proclamation, they will pass
away. We won't need to be proclaiming
anymore. When Christ comes, that's it.
What's there to proclaim? He's here. As
for tongues, languages, they too will
seize. As for knowledge, receiving
knowledge from the Holy Spirit to know
our faith and how to live, it will pass
away. Why? For our knowledge is
imperfect now. So we need more knowledge
and our prophesying is imperfect. But
when the perfect comes, that's Jesus
will come and perfect everything. Right?
>> The imperfect will pass away. And then
what will happen? When I was a child, I
spoke like a child. I thought like a
child. I reasoned like a child. When I
became a man, I gave up childish. Then
I'll be fully mature and know what I
need to know, right? So that
imperfection is gone when the Lord comes
and perfects all things. Because this is
what verse 12 says. Now we see in a
mirror dimly, but then face to face. I'm
going to see the Lord face to face as he
is. Now I know in part. I only know
partially. Then I shall understand fully
even as I have been fully understood. So
there you go.
>> Yes.
I mean
>> I the doubt doesn't come.
>> You scared me. You're not crying, are
you?
>> Me? No.
>> Okay. I thought you were crying. Okay.
Okay. So
that means the Bible says it hasn't
stopped. But secondly, if you are
praying in a language but don't know
what you're saying, so your spirit is
praying, then you don't pray aloud. You
keep it to yourself. Because the Bible
says 1 Corinthians, if you read chapters
12, 13, 14, specifically 14, you are not
to pray in a language or proclaim in a
language that no one understands if you
don't interpret so that they can
benefit. But if you can't interpret,
then you pray to yourself. That's what
Paul says.
>> Yes. I usually do it to myself. Like
>> that's So then there's no problem.
>> Yeah. That's when like if I'm in the
middle of praying like if somebody's
sick and and I just can't
that's when it happens when I just can't
figure out
>> and the spirit takes over and then prays
through you God's will.
>> Right. So that's and it's only after
then I start to doubt like what did you
do? What did you say? Are you there?
>> Doublemindedness again. What did I say?
God says.
>> Yeah. That's and that's it's always
afterwards. So it's like
>> but that's that's what God says. You got
to stop being doubleminded.
>> It's that fear. I'm telling you Sam, you
hit a nail on the head.
>> I told you. But you got to now overcome
it and go by trust God. What he says
what he says, not what I feel. You got
to overcome it, man. Oh, he's he got me.
He's working on me, trust me.
>> Well, thank you so much, Sam. I I needed
to hear that.
>> That's all you had?
>> That is it.
>> All right. The Lord may the Lord set us
all free to walk in the fullness of the
Holy Spirit for the glory of Jesus
Christ.
>> Yes. God bless and praying for you and
your daughters.
>> Appreciate you. Lord willing. Come back
if you have more questions.
>> Yes. Love you, Sam.
>> Take care. God bless. We love you too,
sister. Lord be with you and your
family. Take care.